I'm sitting here with Carl
the UX engineer from Google.
>> Hey Jay.
Thanks for having me.
>> So Carl, let's talk a little bit
about how to get useful feedback
from our users when we're
sitting down with them to test.
>> Hm, so sitting down with users,
there's a variety of ways
that we can go about it.
I think I like to start out with
when we're looking at paper,
I like to start out kind
of an informal setting.
I like to leverage
folks that are nearby.
And involve them in
the brainstorming process
as we start to flesh out
features through our prototype.
>> Ok, and do you start with
a task that you want them to do,
do you start with just like
a flow that you've designed,
do you start with
a blank piece of paper?
>> Sometimes it's actually all three.
It could be any of the above.
There are certain times when you're
trying to conceptualize new features,
things like that.
Simple sketching is
the right place to start.
Just drawing boxes and
arrows and circles, and
things like that on paper is
a really good way to start,
especially when you have folks
that are in non-design roles.
Making them feel comfortable with
paper is a really important part of
the prototyping process, but we want to
collect as many ideas as we can.
So, we want to make sure
that we include those folks.
So, paper sketching is
a good way to start.
We can then evolve into
looking at specific tasks.
So, we might choose to
prototype a specific task.
We might choose to
look at holistic flow.
We might choose to do that
through a set of drawings or
through high fidelity mocks,
maybe that we print out.
And then we can walk through
specific screens within that flow.
>> Awesome.
So, pretend for a moment that I'm
a user and I've sit down with you.
How do you get me to give you
the feedback that you need?
>> So that's a great question.
We like to be really,
really specific about the feedback
that we're looking for.
We really want to make sure that we
don't just leave an open slate, because
when we leave an open slate, folks will
tend to focus on maybe design elements.
Oh, I don't like
the color of that thing,
I don't like the position of that thing.
So we want to very specific with
the feedback that we're looking for.
The best thing to do is come up with a
set of directed questions that will lead
the user in the direction that
you're wanting them to go anyway.
>> Okay.
>> Maybe through a flow or
with a specific screen.
>> Okay, so you'll ask me a set
of directed questions and
I'll sort of go through and
talk about them.
When I'm stuck or confused,
you ask me to do a certain task,
at what point do you intervene and
say the button's right here?
Do you ever do that?
Do you say,
just let them be confused and
record that you're confused
about where this menu button is?
>> Actually it's a really good
thing to record confusion, right?
So when a user gets stumped,
we want to do our best to help
them move through the flow.
But we also really need to capture that
the user got stumped in that case.
The value there is that we can
understand why they got stumped.
We can probe just a little bit more,
understand the difficulty that
they came across with that UI.
Was a particular affordance missing,
is there something that we can do,
maybe highlight it with a different
color, make it bigger, make it bolder,
that kind of thing?
But it also is good to nudge
the user through a flow.
>> Mm-hm.
>> If they do become hung up,
you want to progress through
the entire test, right?
You need to address all of the research
questions that you set out with.
>> Right.
>> And so, letting your user get stuck
and spin in a particular area or
on a particular screen is
something that we want to avoid.
>> So let's talk a little bit about the
questions that we might want to answer.
We've got, you said we need to go
through the entire set of questions,
what kinds of questions do we
want to be asking about an app.
So we've got some design in our head or
on mocks already.
What kinds of questions do we want
to be asking about those mocks,
about that prototype?
>> Sure.
Questions will tend to be
very specific to the prototype itself.
And so you are going to look for things.
Particular interaction
questions might come out.
Does the user know how to get
from screen A to screen B?
Do they know where to find button A?
Can they complete a specific task or
something along those lines
going through a flow?
Can they find something that maybe is
buried three or four screens deep?
>> Right.
>> Those are the types of questions we
want to start with.
>> Okay, perfect.
So in our example app,
we might have questions like,
can a user check off this task?
Does a user know where
the menu button is?
Things like that?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Perfect.
>> Yep.